Evet arkadaşlar Herkese merhaba konumuz
boşluğun Aferin boşluktan Nasıl Zafer
çıkabilir ki dediğinizi diğer gibi çok
güzel sorun Hadi O Zaman başlayalım
Metin dediği gibi adım Hilal Çatak
profesyonel bir kot ve eğitmenim bu gün
sizlerle birlikte 2 adet mutabakat
yapacağız boşluk ben nasıl Zafer çıkar
ona bakacağım ve günün sonunda beş tane
altın anahtarla buluşmalarını
tamamlayacağım Evet arkadaşlar Ben
birkaç um5 soru sormak Böylece kişilerin
kendi hazinelerinin Çeşme etmelerini
sağlayacak ortamlar yaratmak Yani ben
sadece dikkatimi Üzüldüğün sonunda
hazinelerini keşfeden olur bütün
samimiyetiyle isteyen kişi bugün bütün
soruların
ben size Çünkü yüzün anlamı bir şey var
o da her birimiz bir mucize siniz bir
kalbiniz bütün samimiyetiyle da
hayallerine ulaşmayı istiyor Bizim Ben
seni çok iyi farkındayım ki mucize e
kelimesini kullandı Vallahi pek samimi
gelmiyor En azından ilk başta beni
hayatınızı bakıyoruz insanlara bakıyoruz
Oh Ayarlara bakıyoruz Diyoruz ki kendim
için Hazine gibi hissetmiyorum
hissetmiyorum Hatta bazen en
yakınımızdaki kişinin bile Sizi fark
etmediğim için fark etmez arkadaşlar
sizi çok önemli bir şey söyleyeceğim 38
yıllık hayatımı öğrendim en önemli şey
şu ki kendinize fark etmediğiniz bir şey
hiç kimse fark etmeyecek Hadi sonra daha
devam edelim sorun Şu Dünyada kaç kişi
vardır Bu Dünyada kaç tane hayvan vardır
Peki yine binlerce milyonlarca
Evet şimdi diyorum ki bütün dünyada bu
kadar milyarlar ve canlılık arasında
Dünyada sadece bir tane olan eşi benzeri
olmayan bir şey şu anda beni neden
sevdiğini bilmiyorum odanda olsa bu bi
mucize Olur mu olur beni daha beni
alacağım bütün bu milyonlarca canlı
karşında Dünyada başka hiçbir yerde
olmayan bir şey sadece bir tane olan bir
şey senin olanda var hadi onu bul oluyor
arkadaşım o sensin İnansan da inanmasan
da hatta bazen unutsan rasen bir mucize
besin değişim veriyor bu nereden
biliyorsun Biliyor musun Aslında bazen
kendini diyorsun ki ben hiç kimseye
benzemiyorum beni o karşılaştıkları gibi
hastalıklar git kişiler gibi istesem de
olamıyorum diyorsun ya Arkadaşım bu
dünya çay inat o bir benden b
o milyonlarca yıldır yaptığı her şey sen
hiç kimseye benzemiyor yaptın benzersiz
oluyor yaptı Allah de isterdim Hadi fark
et bu dünyada yaratılan her şey kendine
özel bir süper güçler atıldı mesela
kediler kendi Özeldir namaz bir sevgisi
var minnacık karınca Sen ne yapıyorsun
50 kadını taşıyacak mı işte Yani bu
dünyadaki her şey her vardır Hayranım
senin özelliği siparişleri tadı aynı
senin gibi bazen o süper güç kendim de
hiç sevmediğim özelliğinden olabilir
Bazen çok kötü bir halk Şanlı olabilir
bunu iyi düşün bugün sen hiç değişiyor
yani bu ben inanmam boşluklarından
zaferlerin dönüştürmek için becerilerine
çıkma Peki ana konunun Sonuna Geldik
sonrası daha sonra devam etmek istiyorum
hayatında ne farklı olsa zaferlerini
ulaşırsın
bu olarak bu soruyu otomatik verdiğimiz
cevap şu bir şeyler daha iyi oldu
zaferlerini Ulaşırız diye düşünür daha
büyük bir masal daha çok para daha iyi
bir anne baba veya daha iyi bir arkadaş
için senin ilk planda daha iyi olmasını
istediğim Çok yakında Arkadaşlar şu anda
alaka diyorsun ki onun aranıyorsa bana
daha iyi davransa mi kendimi daha iyisi
derim daha çok odaklanın ve hayalim
neyse Onun için çalışma ihtimalin varsa
bakalım Bu da gerçekten Ne oluyor ya
diyorum ki arkadaşım Gerçekten sen daha
iyi davranmaya başladı Kendini iyi
hissetme odaklandığın size olmadığında
ne oluyor yani kötü bulamıyorsun
uzaklaşıyorsun Doğru muyum Arkadaşım çok
iyi fark et çünkü hayatının bütün
sorumluluğunuzda fare gidecek olan bütün
sorumluluğunu Arkadaşıma verdim ve
zafere ulaşacak için güçlü Arkadaşıma
verdim Şimdi sorumluluk kimdeyse Beach
ondadır senden şunu isteyeceğim
bu sorumluluğu da küçük kendini toplamak
istiyorum bunu nasıl yapacaksın biliyor
musun aynı Bütün başarıları ulaşmış ve
başarılarının devam ettirmiş ilham
vermiş bütün insanlar gibi yapacaksın ve
iç sesin senin bir şeyleri daha iyi
olması için gönderen birbirine kendini
soruyu soracaksın aynı onlar gibi ben
niye farklı yapsam zaferleri uğraşırım
ikinci mutabakatı mızda burada
arkadaşlar şimdi asıl konuya girelim
boşluğu zaferi buradaki temel sorun
konuşmak üzere şekilde önce sorulursa
hayatında olan ve olmasını istediklerim
arasındaki boşluk Beni zaferlerini
taşıyacağım becerilerinin kaynağı
olabilir mi buradaki saatten sonra daha
ortaya çıkıyor Bir boşlukta olarak ne
ikisinin içinden zaferler Çıkmak mı
önemli ki arkadaşlar boşluk şu
hayatımızdaki eksiklikler yokluklar
selamlar
12 spor ayakkabısı almak istiyoruz bir
paramız yoktur hayallerinize ulaşmak
istiyorsanız alışkanlıklarımız vardır
brow halde gerçek olmayacağına dair
ihtiyacımız vardır Bütün bunlar boşluk
yaratır gel arkadaşlar bizim boşluk
kaldırmaz bu hayatta görürsünüz bir
boşluk kaldırmaz ve siz o hoşuna olumlu
düşünce etmezseniz hayatımızdaki olumsuz
deneyimlerle orayı doldururum gelişimi
olumsuz deneyimler bir etkisiz hale
gelir ve sizinle konuşmaya başlarsam
yeni işe gideceksiniz size der ki ya Abi
boşver Sen mi yapacaksın Benimki başladı
sonra ne olacak bakın elması Mahallesi
şunu söyler Belki yarın yaparsın o yarın
hiç gelmez Hatta bulduğunda yapıldığını
bulduğumda çok güzel bir kulp takar
belki ağabey yapmış Ama bu zengin yapmış
ama arkadaşı var bir tanıdığı var diye
Şimdi birazdan boşluğun gerçek anlamda
bakacağız mı ikinci etmiştiniz gereken
şey bakalım
o içinden geceleri çıkmak niye önemli
güzel arkadaşım bilgisayar bitti bizi
Eskiyol ışık hızıyla değişiyor bir çoğu
zaman kafa karıştıracağım Peki ben ne
üstüne basıp da geleceğini kuracağım ne
giyeceğim Arkadaşlar artık 21 yüzyıl
geceler çağı ve istersen ver beceriye
gerçekten sahip olmazsam Boğaziçi mezunu
dahil olsam yani Boğaziçi mezunu 17000
tane polis adayının arasında bulurum
polis olmak şahittir benim babam polis
almak için tarifi buysa günün sonunda
bir çocuk Boğaziçi kalmışsa Başka
yerleri vardır diye düşünüyorum doğruyu
arkadaşlar Hemen söylüyorum bir iletişim
içi yaratıcılık 3 problem çözme sadece
bir türlü söylüyor Hayır arkadaşlar
gerçek hayatta böyle sürdük Kaynar nt400
çalıştım ve sektörün en büyük bir bakın
o şansını olduk diyorlar ki Arçelik
Alarko tahannebi farketmez sektör
yaptıkları işten farklı ama baktıkları
şeyler yine bir üniversite mezunu olması
gideceğim görüşürüz hepsini verseniz bir
değişiklik yok ilgilenmiyoruz böyle bir
kavga etme Zaten geliyorlar takdir
edersiniz ki bilgisayar artık
ayrıştırıcı özellikle değil bir Neye
bakıyorlar YouTube Cebir kendisini ifade
edebiliyor mu iletişim iki köprü
arasında yaratıcının kullanabiliyor mu 3
etsin kardeşim ve yaratıcılığını
kullanarak o problemi gerçekten
çözebiliyorum artık Sadece buna
bakıyoruz arkadaşlar geceler konusunda
nefsi artık boşluğun gerçek anlamda
bakalım demiştik hayatımda olan ve
olmasını istediğim istedikleri arasında
boşluk Arkadaşa bu dünyadaki en kıymetli
ve en nadir şey demedi Çünkü boşluk hiç
kimsenin
oy veremeyeceğim isteğin kaynağı boşluk
varsa istek var istek varsa anlam var
bakın etrafınızda Çok iyi gözlemeyi bu
kadar belirsizlikle bu kadar işsizlik
diyorlar insanlar işe gidiyorlar istek
yok yine akşamlar altında öğrenciler
indir babamın okullara gidiyorlar bir
istek yok iki Ne oldu işten eve
gideceksin ben size şunu sormak
istiyorum istek olmadığı bir dünya size
nasıl hissettiriyor Arkadaşlar bunu en
iyi siz biliyorsunuz istek yok Çünkü her
birimiz bir başkasının boşluğunu yani
istediğiniz gibi korkutarak doldururken
kaybettin onu diyorum ki ya birçok nasıl
çocuklar için her şeyi yapmaya razıyım
gerçekten yapmıştım gider diyorlar ki
hocam her şeyi yaptık en yolakları
sağladık çalışmıyor
ama bazen karşılık okuyorum çalışmasa
sonu böyle olacak diyorum hiçbir şey yok
şimdi diyorum yine bir şey yapamıyor ben
de o zaman diyorum ki ne kadar şahane
bir şey söylediğini farkında mısın
kıymetli Anne baba nasıl yani diyor ya
bu ne güzel şahini diyorum ki kendi
küçüklüğünü düşün bir başkası istiyor
diye bir başkası için ne zamana kadar
yapsın biliyor musun ilk yapmayacağım
fırsatı elde edene kadar yaptım sadece
çocuğun da aynı senin gibi başkası
istediğinde korkusuzluğu için yapmayacak
Çünkü korkuyu ait değil sonsuz
olasılıklara cesaretleri güveni Vay ve
bu istek senin zaferle çıkacak en
kıymetli ilk taş gibi şöyle düşünün
Arkadaşlar bir şey gerçekten istiyorsan
o şunlarla Şartlar ne olursa olsun
yaparız bakın hayatımıza gerçekten
istediğiniz her şeyi yaparken
ve kendinizi tarihi bakalım 1453
İstanbul zaferi 29ekim Cumhuriyet Safari
neredeyse olabilecek bütün yokluklarında
boşluklarım olduğu yerde en büyük
zaferler çıkar Çünkü bir şey çok
istediğinizde arkasından yaratıcılık
onun arkasından da kendinize özgü
problem çözme süreci çıkar bu kadar
güzel anlattın ama bu gerçekten bunların
arasında nasıl çıkacak İkisi de hangi
taşları koyacağım diyorsunuz Evet
arkadaşlar tam 25 bin euro değerinde beş
tane sıra devam ediyorum Neden 25000
Euro içinde iki yıllık İngiltere'de
neyim bak on yıl boyunca aldım
motivasyon kendini gerçekleştirme
iletişim eğitimleri var uluslararası
Koçluk Federasyonu olaylı Azer'in
paylaşırım üç kuruş eğitimi var yine
uluslararası portakal sana Elif
sarhoşluğu içinde var oyun Sofia içinde
var Bir süre isim var ben size özet
İyi sabahlar haline getirdim arkadaşlar
ilk anahtar şu neye inandığını fark et
çünkü gerçekleşecek arkadaşlar bütün
hücrelerimiz bilinciniz bilinçaltınız
neye inanıyorsanız onu gerçekleştirmek
üzere hizmetinizde yani bir şey ya çok
olacağını inanıyorsanız da
inanmıyorsanız da iki türlü haklısınız
Çünkü bildiğiniz Hatta çıkartacağım
olmayacağım yapıyorsanız uyumuş gibi
olur ama günün sonunda Aslan olmaz Olur
olacağını gerçekten inanıyorsanız
doğadaki gibi olur yavaş yavaş olur
emeklilere veriyordu bir insanı da
mutlak aldım çok iddialıyım hemen bir
örnek yapalım ve birlikte görelim
Gerçekten böyle oluyor mu hazırsınız bu
oyun oynayacağız ve hayal gücünüzle
yapacağımız oynayacağız Peki şu an bir
limon Hayal etmenizi istiyorum sarı
ekşisu bilim ol helal ettiniz mi Star
şimdi onu elinize alın ağırlığına bakın
mengili görün kokusunu istedim
daha sonra gibi mutfakta ikiye kesin
Arkadaşlar şu bıraktığını görün
çekirdekleri bir gün farkedin bir
gerçekten soğuk su daha keskin geldi
burnunuzu şimdi limonu yarısından razı
sıkılmaya başladım bıraksın ekşiliğini
farkedin Ne oldu ben geliyorum hocam
burada Burası biraz kaşındırıyor diye
bir şey soracağım gerçekten bir limon
var mıydı Yoktu beni bir silahla
onlarında bütün hücrelerinde Onun için
Hazırlandı mı O yüzden zaferlerini
ulaşmak için neye inanman gerekiyordu
onay Lan oğlum de kendimi soru
sorabilirsin gerçekten değil aslında
sömürü mümkün olur Bunu kalbini bir
Şimdi ikinci anahtarı geliyoruz ikinci
Allah'ta BİM'den alınan var Yeniden
Allah'ın vermek çok kıymetli arka Sen
kimsin hayatımda Oğlum saat liralar var
bu hayatın helal et bence
bu ve o Anılar hala olsun dilimler
halinde ise bir dayağımızdan saat şu
anda dönüşüne kadar yere gitmeye
çalışırız operalar sağa geriye çeker
şöyle düşünün ne kadar giyindin Allah'ın
vermeye devam etmek zorundayız
Arkadaşlar bir ki ilki diyene kadar o
anneciğim bir anlam vereceğiz İyi ki bu
başıma gelmiş demek için bundan nasıl
bir yere anlam çıkartabilir kendi
hayatından bir örnek vereceğim hemen çok
kızacağım arkadaşlar Eğer biraz ama
gerçekten yeniden anlamı vermeseydim de
onu kendi hayatımız hazinesi
dönüştürmesi giydin bugün Sizin
karşınızda olması da başka bir yerde
olurdum şimdi 2018 yılında bir kız
çocuğu kaybetmiş 2 yaşındaki olarak
uyanık Siz de var otizm teşhisi konmuş
İstanbul için kariyerini oğlum daha
yoğun umuduyla bırak Aydın'a gelmiş
geldikten alsak sonra oğlum babasının
kendi yolunda gitmek kararıyla
bu tanımadığı bir şey de dinlemiş Burası
Yok ya İki buçuk yaşındaki çocuk almış
bir kadındım ve inancım yüksek
arkadaşımla konuşuyorum dedim ki ben
oğlum için ayaklarının üstünde dimdik
duracağım mıyım Aydın'da koştuk
yapacağım dedi o da haklı olarak bazı
sorular sordu Dedi ki Hilal aydınlanmış
yapan var mı bizim yok çünkü İzmir'i
İstanbul'dan gelmiş bugüne kadar peki
dedin ofisim vardı ona Yok param var mı
O hiç yok dağılan birisi var mı Aydın'da
bir kişiyi tanımıyorum dedin ona göre
bana bir şeyler Emin misin Çok istiyorum
ama o kadar derin değildi Tamam o sırada
beş yaşında küçük bir kız çocuğu geldi
yanıma ağabey Kulağıma bir şey söyledi
arkadaşlar ve ondan sonra dedim ki
hayatımda hiç bu kadar iyi olmamıştım o
kız çocuk biliyormusunuz arkadaşlar
zaman saçtan yerin dibine girdim bir
hatıramı sahibi bilim Beş yaşındaki
küçük halim her anlattığında ye
eve geçtim suçluluk duydum bir anım
vardı sanki ona bambaşka bir bakış
açısından bakıp bir hazine olduğunu
keşfedene kadar alıp şöyle annemle ilk
çocuğu Yanılmaz konularını ayrı yetişmiş
mi arkadaşlar o kadar korumacı bir şey
hayal edin doktor doktor 409 pastamı
yetiştirdiniz bu çünkü bağışıklık
sistemi yok İlk defa tek başıma beş
yaşında evden çıkacağım Senin içindeki
bakkala gidip yumurtalık gireceğim Hoca
giydiriyorlar başını kapatıyorlar
ilmeğin bir pembe cliolarda güzelden
bakacağız ben gideceğim şimdi doğru
Çocuklar ne yapar kafasına Ya gidip
gelirdim yatsın öyle Hayır öyle
yapmamışım böyle yapmışsın arkadaşlar da
aklından çıkar çıkmaz gözünün önünü
açmışım sonra kafa basmışım yetmedi
ağzını açmışım ne yağmurları toplaya
toplaya bakkala gitmiştim değil kalıyor
sanırım kırmışım ne olarak sen aile
meclisinde İşte bizim kız da ağzını açtı
yapımıdır topladı bir anlatmadı ben çok
utanırdım
Ya anne başka bir şekilde bakma şansım
oldu ve İnanın bana anlattığı hikaye
gerçekten duydum Çünkü bana Aslında
diyordu ki Bir şimdi ne derse desin
Umursama kendin oluyordu yeni kasa
Yağmur ağzında topla 2 Nissan S15
yaşındasın bilmiyor musun asla biraz
anlaşılabileceğini Dalga geçileceğini 3
diyordu ki biraz Sen soğuk sevecek kadar
yavru Tadına bakmak isteyecek kadar Bu
hayatı Aşıksın diyordu bana ne o bir
planı Elif Güler dedi Sen gerçekten bu
işi yapmak istiyor musun Şimdi artık
Bitsin Umursama kalbimden geçenleri yap
kendin ol dedi ikincisini ki evet risk
alacaksın Çünkü çünkü olmayabilir ama
hatırlat Hilal gibi sen Zafer'den değil
Sakarya sorumlusun 3. olarak dedi ki
hayatı o kadar aşık oldum Oğlum senin
gözündeki Işık ben kendi dünyasından
çıkıp şimdi dünyada gelebilsin
arkadaşıma döndüm Benimki ondan sonra
şişme kadar emin olmamıştım olma döndüm
dedim ki anneciğim hiçbir
çok tatlı oynamazsak ben seni kamyon
serin hiç kimse gelmezse sorunlar Çünkü
biz onlara gidelim gidecek Hiçbirimiz
olmazsa esnafları teknik gezeriz
iletişim kurarız Ben seni o gün
içerisinde yaşamış olursam olayım
şarkılarla gülücüklerle konuşacağım Yeni
şarkılardan öpücüklerle uyandıracağım
dedin Ne oldu biliyor musunuz Tamam
şimdi verdikten Alsay sonra kendi işim
vardı aydın enişte Hani bunlardan
okullarına Koçluk yapıyordum daha da
ödenmesi 5 doktorun Şaşkın bakışları
arasında olmak kullanıyor eksikliğine
bağlı 30 bitişi tamamiyle tatlı herşeyi
yeniden anlamda düşüncesine geliyor
süreyi doğru kullanması bırak düşmüş
sorularını değiştir hayatını değiştin
bu olumsuz şeyler var olumsuz
karşılaştırmada otomatik olarak bir
soruyoruz biliyormusunuz arkadaşlar yine
ben ne demek benim başıma geliyor Suçlu
kim nerede hata yapıyorum Bakın bu
sorular hiç birşey olmadığı gibi aynı
şeyi versiyonları yaşarken bulurum
hayatta iki onun yerine soracağım ilk
Soracağım soru şu Arkadaşlar bir şu anda
en kötü durumda bile iyi olan ne Bunlar
çok kıymetli iyi ulaştı bulamazsam ne
yapacağını bilelim gün sonra kalacağını
bildiğim ama ayağını koyacağız eminim
olmaz sallanırken Bugün o yüzden bir iyi
olanı İkincisi çok kıymet mi Çünkü bu
iki soruyu Sormazsam poljana kısmında
kalırım bundan ne öğreniyorum Ben
hayatımı değiştiren sorun üçüncüsü ise
seçenekleri neler yaparız Oldu mu Olmadı
mı yaptın başladın mı bu gerçek değil
Hayat sonsuz olasılıklar sadece doğaya
bakmak yeter O yüzden en az beş tane
Çok teşekkür ettim kendinize ki bu Siz
yok Süt de çok yavaş şeydi araştırın
olarak besin dikkat en uygulaması içi
videolu en basit en kolay adıma indirin
bir adım atıp hatırlayın bir ile başlar
her şeyi giren büyüktür sıra geldi 4.
anahtara Arkadaşlar bu alışkanlıklarını
değiştirip kaderini değiştirir İnşirah
Suresi'nde diyor ki Biz insanı çabası
kaderini çabasına bağlı kalıp Babanız
nerede biliyormusunuz arkadaşlar günlük
alışkanlıklarınıza kaçta yapıyorsun
kaçta kalkıyor seçimlerle konuşuyorsun
Ne seyrediyorsun kendine yalnız
bırakıyorsun kendine hayalet nasıl bir
sonraki sık Nasıl olmasını istiyorsun o
günden bugüne bak bir de ki kendine o
hayalleri gerçekleştirmek için o zafere
ulaşmak için bugün hangi
alışkanlıklarından rahatla zamanı geldi
ilk sorun gol bugün hangi alışkan
bu etmeyen hangi alışkanlığı en az beş
tane bunları istiyorum 20 tuşu bir
bırakacağım hissettim onun yerine
koyacağım 500 sonraki zafere ulaşmak
için bugün hangi alışkanlıkları hayatımı
Anladın mı geldi yine beş tane
arkadaşlar hastalıkların değişti Kaderim
değiştin son anahtarı geliyorum Üstün bu
kararları verirken önceleri ne olacak V
anahtar ahlak ve Erdem işçilerin neler
unutmasın olabilir ahlaklı nasıl oluruz
zafere ulaşmak için hangi andaki gelir
bana yardımcı olur mu yaşamak için ne
yapacak mı arkadaşlar basamak yapacağız
bir kere sordum zaten biliyorsunuz Bunu
tam tersini söyleyeceğim şimdi size
Zafer denize ulaşmak için neleri
yapmayacaksınız Hatta gözümü
zaferlerinden Seni sizinle vazgeçmem
gerekirse değiştiğinden gerekse bile
nerede yapma
işte bunun cevabı ahlak bilgileriniz
bilirler şimdi almış Tanrım dediği gibi
insanı ayakta tutan iskelet ve kas
sistemi değil ahlak verdim ilçeleridir
Bu soruyu iki sene önceki sorduğunda
Cesur ve harita çocuklarla söyle Biliyor
musunuz hocam ben Sizin canınız gibi
yaparım başarmak için ne diyorsunuz dedi
küçük Teşekkür ederim de bir konuşacağız
bunu konuşmadık mı olmuş olmadı
göstermiyorsun bak etrafımda başarmak
için her şeyi yapacak insanlarla dolu
teşekkür ederim dedi dedim Ben bugün
senin karşında olmak için senin canım
yapmış olsaydı bunu ister miydin Dedim
yap ya dedi mi Okey peki arkadaşım canım
yapmış yapmış olsaydı bunu ister miydin
dedim yat yat dedim süper yaklaşıyoruz
Çünkü bana en sevdiğin kişi söyler misin
dedim annem dedi neden dedim anneni çok
seviyorsun anlattım o zaman dedim ki ben
bugün Aydın'da senin karşında bu için
vermek uğruna annenin kovala gitseydin
de şu anda gerçekten gerçekçi olsaydı
istemedim dedim ne biliyor musun
ben istemem dedim ki Tabii ki istemezsin
güzel arkadaşım Tabii ki istemezsin
sadece ismini bilmiyorum Çünkü sana
sadece başarmak için ne yapacağını
sordular ben Karanlığa ait değilsin ki
sorularını değişti hayatım değiştirme
Ahmet Erdem içilebilir güzel arkadaşım
bütün bunları yapmak için bütün bunları
yapmak için bir mucize ihtiyacım yok şu
Çünkü mucizenin kendisi sensin beni
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
boşluklarını iyi bak çok